And now the old scout master.
One more important revelations in life is finding out that you got two ears and one mouth,
And there's probably a good reason for that.
Hey, this is podcast number 155..
Well, welcome back to this edition of the scout master podcast.
This is Clark Green.
Let's take a look in the mailbag and see what's going on. this week
We heard from TC and he's in Medina Ohio with PAC 3501..
He says: thanks for all you do, Clark.
I'm enjoying my son's scouting journey as much as my own.
I think that happens quite a bit.
My son's a Cub Scout.
He's in a Baradun.
If possible, I'd like to give a shout out to our Cub master.
He'll be stepping down in February of this year after years of service to spend more time with his boys in scouting as a dad.
Here's a shout out to Andrew West, who is the Cub master of PAC 3501 in Medina Ohio.
Andrew, thank you.
Obviously your time as Cub master well spent and it's meant a great deal to those boys and their families.
And you know, Andrew, just between you and me, I've spent my time as a Cub master too.
It can be quite a challenge and it's a big job in scouting
And I certainly appreciate anybody who puts the time in to make that important work happen
And I also wish you continued success as you follow your son's through scouting.
David wrote in to say I enjoy your podcast
Great
Well, thanks for listening, David.
I certainly do appreciate hearing from you.
John Nelson said I wanted to say I've been following the blog for the past few months and catching up on yours. worth your materials.
Your recent post on autism and scouting is an excellent topic and I appreciate your analysis.
Go take a look at that over at scoutmastercgcom- autism and scouting-
And it talks a little bit about a group that is working very hard to raise awareness in the scouting community of working with boys who are identified as autistic.
There's some wonderful resources available from them and I think they're doing a wonderful job.
Thank you,
And there's another shout out to the folks at autism and scouting:
Hey, let's take a minute to check in with our friends at Conahoe Creek.
I've got Bill Fleming on the phone here.
You're doing great, Clark.
How are you doing
So? last week we started talking about this scout gear bundle over at conahoecreekcom.
You put this gear bundle together based on your longtime experience in scouting and testing gear and things like that for scouts to have good quality, durable gear without spending a minute of money,
And I think it's a great idea.
And one of the things you've chosen for this bundle is the Eureka ST sleeping pad.
Now I have one similar to this and I love it.
It's extraordinarily comfortable.
They're very, very durable.
They're good value for money.
And tell me a little bit about it.
You'll see real often guys backpacking and they'll have their pads strapped down on the outside and it's constantly falling off on the trail.
Yeah, that's,
You know, slowing down the whole group,
But these things collapse down to a small size, to 3 by 10 inches
That could literally fit inside your backpack.
And this one is very durable.
And not only that: the size and the thickness is much more than some of the other types of pads and gives you a lot more comfort in that regard too,
And that's just one of the selections that's made in this gear bundle.
It's just like having a personal shopper with a lot of experience: help you pick out gear that's going to last a long time and that is going to serve you very well, and you're going to be able to get it at a good price.
Bill, you'll customize this any way people want right
For their particular climate, and just because it's in the scout bundle doesn't mean it has to stay in there.
You'll switch things out and do whatever they need to get them the gear that they really want right.
Oh, absolutely,
In fact. if you have any questions, don't hesitate to contact us, and you know that's what we're all about at Conahoe Creek.
Well, thanks, Bill. Everybody get yourselves over to conahoecreakcom-
C-O-N-O-H-O-Creekcom,
And when you get ready to check out, use the special coupon code for listeners to the Scoutmaster podcast, C-G-1-1-3..
In this podcast, in Scout Mastership, in seven minutes or less, we're going to handle both ends of the spectrum.
That's right. I want to tell you a little bit about Weebelow's Den visiting our troop recently,
And then we're also going to talk about some measures that you can take to retain older Scouts,
And then I've got two or three email questions to answer, and that's going to do it for this podcast.
So let's get started, shall we?
Scout Mastership in seven minutes or less.
Just the other night we hosted a couple of Weebelow's Den's at a troop meeting. They had come to visit us
And I got to say I'm never really sure what the best way to handle this is.
We've done all kinds of things. We've tried the PowerPoint presentation to the parents while the boys were off
doing some super special activity that the Scouts had planned for them and just absolutely fallen flat.
And I think this one went real well, And here's why It's kind of surprised us.
I mean, it was January, We were just coming back from the holidays
And you know we kind of threw it together. to tell you the truth,
Let me tell you how it worked. The committee chairman talked to them for a bit about basic troop functions
and administrative things and what it would be like to have a son in the troop. from that standpoint,
I had conferences and other things that I needed to do.
So while he was doing that I took care of business. and then I came in after about 20 minutes
and he introduced me to the parents and I said a brief hello and explained to them
that probably the best way for them to learn about our scout troop was to talk to our Scouts.
You know that I would be happy to talk to them for as long as they like,
but that I didn't think that that would paint as good a picture as our Scouts would.
One thing that we always do with Weeblows or visiting the troop
is. we send the Weeblows off with the Scouts to do whatever they're doing
and the parents come into another room and we spend some time talking to them
and fielding questions and whatnot.
But just before I headed to that parents' room I asked a scout who joined the troop last year
if he could spare about 10 minutes.
I checked with his patrol leader make sure that was okay
And he said he'd be happy to do that and I asked him to follow me.
I didn't tell him what we were going to be doing
And I brought him into that parents' room and I introduced him to a group of parents
and I explained that the scout had no idea why he was there
but that he'd be happy to talk to them
and answer any question they may have about what he's been up to for the past year.
And he looked at me a little confused but I reassured him. it wasn't a test,
It was just a chance for these parents to talk to him
and he found his feet pretty quick
and I don't really know what they asked him or what he answered,
because I left the room to get a scout who had been in the troop for two or three years.
When I returned, I thanked the first year scout for his time
and sent him back to his patrol and introduced the next scout,
explaining he'd been one of us for two or three years,
And again left him in the room with the parents while he answered questions
and I went to find our senior patrol leader.
I asked the senior patrol leader if he could spare a few minutes
and once again I really didn't tell him what he was going to be up to
and I took him back to the parents' room,
sent our three-year veteran back to his patrol,
introduced the senior patrol leader
and the parents were able to ask him questions
and I went out to get my next two speakers.
I would like to say that we had carefully planned this,
but it just was a happy accident that two of our alumni were visiting at the time.
I mean, it was, you know, we were in the middle of that big winter break for college,
Found them in the troop meeting and I asked them if they had a few minutes
and they followed me to the parents' room
where I thanked the senior patrol leader for his time
and let him get back to his work,
and I introduced our two alumni by saying something like you know.
so far. tonight you've heard from a scout who joined the troop last year,
one who's been around for three years,
and our senior patrol leader who's been around for five or six years-
and I want to introduce you to two young men who were scouts in this troop.
They both became Eagle Scouts.
They're home for their winter break.
Now you get a look at where your son could be headed if he joins our troop.
Go ahead and ask any question you like
and by the time they're done
you will have formed a pretty good picture of what a boy experiences
all the way through the years he can spend with our troop.
Now those two fellows fielded questions for five or 10 minutes or so
and I finished up with, you know, my five minutes of disjointed rambling.
I can edit the stuff I say on the podcast
and it just makes me sound a little more intelligent that way.
I wish I could do that when I was speaking to a group, you know.
But we dismissed the parents meeting
and one of the assistant scout masters had some pictures of our trip to Switzerland
to show them if they were interested in taking a look at it,
and they could also go out and observe what was going on with the scouts
before we had our closing.
I was really happy with that Webelez visit.
Now we've done the deal where we've brought scouts in to talk to parents before,
but it was a little more formal and this was a little less formal
and I think it worked pretty good
and I think that the parents got more out of it too.
I'm not exactly sure what our scouts had planned for the Webelez
for that meeting.
They didn't turn themselves inside out,
but they knew that the Webelez were coming
and they were ready for them
and took them through the meeting as they would in other patrol,
and I saw some happy faces at the end.
so I'll be looking forward to hearing how the whole visit was received
and see if we get some Webelez joined the troop out of it.
Now that's one end of the spectrum-
bringing new boys into the troop-
and the other end of the spectrum
is keeping our older scouts active and involved,
and it's always a perennial concern.
We bring our hands a lot over losing older scouts
and many troops do have a problem keeping them around.
I think a lot of times the standard response
is amping up the wow factor of the program
and trying to keep these boys entertained,
but I've never really been fond of that approach.
I keep my hand in at our summer camp
and work with the camp director and the program director a bit.
We are under constant pressure for the summer camp programs
to add yet another older boy program
to entice them back for another year,
because we think that they're not going to be interested
unless there's some big flashy, entertaining thing going on.
After watching this go on for 25 years or so,
these programs kind of come and go.
they don't really end up pushing the attendance numbers all that much
and they drain a lot of resources.
I do believe older scouts want to have a great time
and do fun, exciting things,
but all scouts want to do that.
Simply turning up the wow factor
doesn't really keep older scouts engaged
and that's because they're looking for much more than just fun.
What really gets them interested,
What really keeps them around?
That's a pretty simple answer
and it's kept our older scouts involved
well past the time you'd normally expect.
When we're rechartering each year.
our dropped scout survey usually includes
two or three older scouts because they aged out,
not because they've lost interest.
Here's 10 things that we do to keep older scouts engaged.
Number one is our older scouts run the troop
with real independent responsibility
for the welfare of the troops program,
and I could just stop there
and that would be enough, I think.
but that's tremendously important.
If they're not running things,
if they don't have that real independent responsibility,
they're not going to be interested for very long.
Number two is our adult leaders
are taught to encourage and support
our scouts from a respectful distance.
We do our best to let them live their own lives
and not to interfere,
and I think that's a pretty important aspect.
Number three is we accept
that mistakes are inevitable
and that they're not all punishable crimes.
We work hard to be encouraging and understanding.
when a boy steps out of line
or there's some kind of difficulty,
We try and give them as much latitude as possible
to make mistakes or errors of judgment,
without invoking the Nuremberg trial
or anything like that.
It's not a boys will be boys atmosphere,
not at all.
but we understand that they will
indeed make mistakes
and misjudgements
and we're prepared to deal with them
in, hopefully, a constructive and encouraging manner.
Number four: we let these older scouts
be who they are,
and what I mean by that is
sometimes that older scout
shows up with purple hair
or his choice of a hat
or some other kind of costume-
and when I say costume,
you know what I mean- right,
The stuff they wear to show
their rugged individualism
so that they look like
every other rugged individual.
I found that if we respond to all this
with nothing more than a slightly raised eyebrow
and we accept
that this is a stage
that many boys go through,
we're not going to make a big giant deal out of it.
Okay, so you want to do the purple hair thing
for a while? well,
I've seen that before.
you want to wear that crazy hat?
okay? well,
I was a boy once too and I probably look
just about as silly as you do now.
let them be themselves
and don't make a big giant deal
over these things. that are just stages of growth.
Number five: we accept that
not every older scout will be at every single
outing and meeting.
I guess what I'm saying is
is: we look at the glass as being half full.
Beyond that, we also want them
to take part in other things- in the community,
in school and in their church and their family,
and when they do,
they take what they've learned in scouting
out with them.
Number six: we encourage a healthy
culture of positive peer pressure.
we try to celebrate accomplishments
and minimize failures.
and that healthy peer pressure.
it's a very positive thing,
not only for our older
scouts but for our younger ones as well.
Number seven: we try
and build an atmosphere
of respect, real concern
and care for the welfare of our younger
scouts. We make it the first
priority of everyone
in the troop. We monitor for
any kind of cruelty or bullying or hazing
and we manage it right as soon
as we know about it.
This is another one of those things that
you can't get too worked up
about when it occurs,
because it's something that you should
expect and you should be prepared to handle.
Again, not a boys
will be boys atmosphere
of permissiveness, but
authoritative leadership from the adults
when these types of things happen
and we step in and we make what
corrections we need and
we keep that positive emphasis
in all of our actions.
Number eight: we don't nitpick
the decisions made by our older scouts
that offer much in the way of unsolicited
advice. Do you remember how you learned
to cook?
You made
mistakes along the way, You tried
some things out that weren't a very good idea
and it's very
tempting as an adult to watch
these guys try to do something and want
to fix it for them or want to
bring your advice to it,
but sometimes you just have to let them be.
Let them give it a try, even though
you've seen it a hundred times and you know it's not going to work.
let them let them at it. When they figure
out it doesn't work, they'll move on to something
else and they might even ask your advice
if you aren't over there poking your nose in it.
Number nine: we do our best
to give our older scouts plenty of time to spend
with each other. We have
an expectation that they work actively
with younger scouts, but we
want to also make sure that they get to hang
out with their friends. I mean, that's one
of the big reasons that they're there.
Number ten: and before I say
number ten, I'm sharing with you
information that was in a
post that I put up on
the blog a couple of weeks ago.
and boy, you all are sharp
because within minutes,
literally minutes- of this
post going up, I had
objections to number ten.
and number ten is: we don't
pay much attention when
a scout doesn't wear a uniform,
If the choice is having
him there without a uniform
or his dropping out because
we get all nitpicky and we force
him to wear a uniform.
I'd rather have him there Now for sure.
that raises your eyebrows because
uniforming is one of the methods of scouting
and scouts ought
to be required to wear uniforms. and
you know. I agree that uniforming
is a method, and if you show
me a rule or regulation from
scouting literature that says boys are
required to wear uniforms, I will follow
it. There are a lot of
expectations and encouragements to wear
uniform, but no policy
requires it. I wear
mine, as do the other adults
and most of the other scouts, and that's good.
Our senior patrol leader wears
his uniform. He always encourages
others to follow his example,
but he's not going to use any
negative reinforcement if they don't.
Once again, if the choice is
between keeping a boy
involved without a uniform being
worn all the time or
losing him because we make
him wear it, I will choose
the scout every time.
Now, the rule for wearing
a uniform will be
found in the uniform and insignia
guide on page 5 under
the heading official policy, and I'll
read it to you here. While
wearing the uniform is not mandatory,
it is highly encouraged.
The leaders of scouting, both
volunteer and professional, promote the
wearing of the correct,
complete uniform on all suitable
occasions. And as with
any of these methods of scouting,
I can't force a boy to wear
uniform. I encourage him. I set
an example by wearing my own,
but I won't force him. I don't
force boys to participate in the
outdoor program. I encourage them.
I set an example by going myself,
but I'm not going to force them to do
that. I don't force boys to use
the patrol system. I encourage them,
but I won't force them. I don't force
them to work with younger scouts.
I encourage them. I set the example
by working with them. I don't
force scouts to do their job.
They take on a position of
setting an example by being responsible,
but I can't force them to be
responsible, nor will I try.
Scouting is not about
scouts meeting my
expectations. It's about them
forming and meeting their own
expectations. Boys are in scouts
voluntarily. They aren't there to
do as they're told and to toe the
line. They're there to build
something for and about themselves.
I won't force.
I'll hang it in the street by the street by,
And we will dance into the street by street by.
Yeah, you're my favorite all-time boy scout.
You're my favorite all-time boy scout.
He's my favorite all-time boy scout.
Write me a letter, send it by name
Email. that is folks,
And here's an answer to one of your emails.
Hey, here's some email questions that have come in.
John Hibner is in Indiana
And he says: do you have any suggestions
On how to get a dysfunctional troop to turn the corner
And operate properly using the patrol method?
Our troop historically has had about 20 active scouts.
We've managed to get a handful of older scouts
To the youth leader training,
But it seems to wear off in a matter of months.
I have an inter-battle, like most scout leaders,
With keeping from interfering with troop operations,
But it's frustrating for me because it seems
Boys never get to the point where they operate
As scouting was intended 90% of the time
And, truth be told, sometimes our troop
Is nothing better than a loosely organized boys club
Where all they want to do is play a game
During the entire meeting.
Well, John, a lot of this begins, of course,
With the adults who are involved with the troop,
And you all need to sit down
And kind of hit the reset button
And say: what are we really trying to do here
And do a little bit of studying
And talking amongst yourselves.
Let the boys play games in their meetings. for now-
And you'll get to that later-
The first thing you've got to do
Is you've got to get all the adults
Who are involved with the troop on the same page
And make a commitment to this.
Then you need to realize that the patrol method
And youth leadership is not throwing a switch.
It's not either, or
It's not. well, the boys just play games
For every meeting because you know
It's a boy-led troop and this is what they wanted to do.
Nope, they need some structure
And they need some information.
Now you would think that you would be able
To send them to youth leader training
And they would get that structure and information
And they would bring it back to the troop.
But that is not a very common occurrence,
To tell you the truth.
Youth leader training is a good start,
But unless the adults in the troop
Are ready to work with the structure
And information that was imparted
At youth leader training,
Things are going to wear off.
The corner you're going to turn
Is going to begin with the adults.
You're going to sit down
And you're going to sort things out
And shape an attitude in the scouts
Where they understand the importance
Of these things and they begin
Putting them into practice.
What this looks like from where you sit
And what it looks like
From where the scouts are
Is a trick of perspective.
We've said over and over again
That when the patrol method is in practice
It can look very messy
And disorganized and chaotic.
But you need to develop
And cultivate the perspective
For seeing that it's working.
Boys have a lot of instinctual ability
To do this
But they're kind of
Stumbling through it
And working it out as they go along
And it looks like a mess
And you need to learn to look for
Those encouraging signs
That they're beginning to get it
And then cultivating that
As they go along.
But it's a big job
But it's very, very possible
And it certainly works.
John, I hope that helped.
Do get in touch with me if I can help you any further.
Dave wrote in about a post that we
Had last week about a change to the Merit Badge card.
Now
The change simply was in the wording
Underneath the unit leader's signature,
Because
The old Merit Badge card
Indicated that this was the unit leader's approval
That a scout was qualified to take the Merit Badge
And that's been largely misunderstood
By some of us
Who think that the process
That we go through before we sign
A blue card to qualify
A scout to take a Merit Badge
Means that we're going to make a decision
About what Merit Badges they should be working on
And when and at what age,
And we're going to prevent them from
Doing ones we don't think they ought to do,
Or with counselors that we don't like
Or something like that.
That's never been policy,
And so the new wording underneath
That unit leader's signature
That the Merit Badge has been discussed with the scout
And we have given him
The name of at least one qualified counselor.
In response to that post,
Dave wrote in and he said
This is a great improvement
And should help scouts who may have a leader
Who's gone slightly astray.
I would like to get some guidance on
Who can sign a Merit Badge card.
Unit leader is intentionally
Vague to allow for the
Leaders of troops and crews and teams,
While unit leader typically
In a troop typically means scout master,
I have found
No documentation that says it's limited
Only to a scout master doing this.
I'm an assistant scout master
And I count myself as a unit leader.
I'm looking at this
That the literature tells us that scout masters
Do scout master conferences, but I know
In practice a lot of assistant scout masters
Do scout master conferences as well.
Our troop has about 70 scouts-
Hey, Dave, good job there-
And our scout master wants
Me to sign blue cards,
But our committee chair does not want me
Signing blue cards or doing conferences,
Stating that it's the scout master's
Job alone.
You know, truthfully, with 70 plus scouts,
I don't believe it's very realistic to ask
One man to do all of
This by himself,
And it tends to be a disservice to the scouts
To do so.
Well, Dave, I agree with what you've said there
And, as you noted, all the literature
Talks about this being the unit leader
Of the troop. indeed, that is a scout master
And while it's not
Explicitly explained,
Our common sense should lead us
To understand that, especially in a troop
With a lot of scouts,
A scout master is going to delegate
Some of those responsibilities to his assistants.
It's pretty clear that this is
The responsibility of the unit leader,
But common sense tells us
That a good leader delegates
And that it's certainly fine
For an assistant scout master to conduct
A scout master's conference or to sign a blue card,
So long as they're trained
And that they have been delegated
To do so by the unit leader, the scout master.
Troy Barber is the scout master
Of troop 994
In Fairfax station, Virginia.
He says I love the podcast.
It's helped me over the past couple of years
After I became a scout master for our troop.
I have a question about the proper procedures
For
Transferring signed off requirements
From one scout handbook
To a new one. I have a second class scout
That recently transferred to our troop.
His old scout handbook is falling apart
And he and his parents came
To me
With photocopies of the signed off
Requirements in his old book
Along with his new handbook
And asked if I could sign those requirements
In his new book. I've looked all around
But I can't find any guidance on this.
Do I transfer the requirements and sign them
Off under my own initials?
Do I transfer the dates and the original
Initials and add my initials to the
Requirements? Do I have the scout
Just to attach the photocopies
Or original pages to his old
Book? I'd appreciate your thoughts.
I checked in with the national advancement
Team on this Now. I was pretty sure
That any one of the approaches that you
Described would be fine. They backed
Me up on that and they said: yeah, use your common
Sense and make sure the records are transferred
Into the new handbook. I think
We've all run into this at one time or another.
You know, a scout handbook
Gets some pretty hard use and it can kind of disintegrate,
And boys do have
A propensity for losing them once in a while.
So recreating
The
Requirements that have already been signed off
In a new book- There's lots of different ways
To do it. If we keep with the spirit of the thing,
We can take any one of those methods
That you suggest to Troy
To certify
His new handbook
And hopefully it'll hold together for the next
Few years. I appreciate everybody
For sending in an email question.
You're certainly welcome to join them.
We'd love to hear from you
And you're going to find out how to get in touch
In just a moment.
Thanks for listening to this edition of the
Scoutmaster podcast.
Here's how you can keep in touch:
Read the scoutmaster blog at
ScoutmasterCGcom
While you're there. you can subscribe to receive
Updates to the blog and the podcast
By email.
You can subscribe to the podcast on iTunes
And, when you do, leave a comment
Or review or rating if you would,
You can access the scoutmaster podcast
On your mobile device and you can
Get in touch with us
Scoutmaster podcast on your mobile device
Through Stitcher Smart Radio.
Get details about how to make that happen
At Stitchercom.
You can experience all the wonders of
ScoutmasterCGcom
In the vast panorama of
Social media outlets.
We're at Scoutmaster blog on Facebook,
ScoutmasterCG
On Twitter.
To gain admittance to the exclusive
ScoutmasterCG Circle search for ScoutmasterCG
On Google Plus,
Please do email me, Clark Reen,
With your comments and questions
And wild ideas at ScoutmasterCG
At Verizonnet.
The Scoutmaster blog
And the Scoutmaster podcast
Are not official publications of the Boy Scouts of America,
Nor are they endorsed or sponsored
By the Boy Scouts of America.
Goodness, no, it's just me
Talking into a microphone, trying to lend a hand
To scout leaders and have a little bit of fun
Along the way.
And speaking of fun, here is our
Bid and Pell. Sir Robert,
Good luck to you and Group Camping.
Why? thank you, sir,
Until next time.
Thank you,
Thank you.